emmanuel macron wants a second term as
president something no incumbent in
france has managed in the last 20 years
if he succeeds he'd be only the fourth
french leader to do so since the
beginning of the fifth republic in 1958.
marine le pen from the far right
national party is one of 11 other
candidates standing in his way
she promises in her manifesto to curb
immigration and make it illegal for
muslims to wear headscarves in public
spaces but her campaign has focused on
the cost of living crisis it's the
number one concern for french voters
ahead of the war in ukraine the
environment and healthcare
my concern is her future of course i am
worried about cost of living but the
main thing for me is the actions needed
to fight climate change
i want everything to change that we go
back to a sweeter life where we stop
talking about money and about profit and
put being human at the heart of the
discussion
the international situation is scary
with a war going on in europe i think
it's a big worry and then unemployment
is also a concern even if now it's
slaughtering
far left candidate jean-luc mellon is
hoping to make it to a second round of
voting that'll be in two weeks if no
candidate gets more than 50 percent of
the vote and that's never happened since
france started directly electing its
presidents in 1965. the issue of
refugees
also is the second aspect
that
i mean
as a consequences of crazy ukrainian
crisis
that could have an impact on the vote
today and
after two weeks
polls close at 8pm on sunday in major
cities 7pm in the provinces a concern
this time is there'll be a low turnout
because people feel the result is a
foregone conclusion a pre-election poll
suggested a third of registered french
voters won't bother to cast their
ballots that would be a record now
there's no exit polling here but we'll
get a good indication of who might go
through to the second round of voting
just after 18 hours gmt that's when
figures are released from ballots
counted where the polls closed an hour
earlier
bernard smith al jazeera paris
all right natasha butler joins us live
from paris natasha those early turnout
figures weren't looking so good is it
picking up now
well at this polling station in central
paris has certainly been quite a lot of
people coming to vote there was quite a
queue behind me a short while ago but it
seems that perhaps that is not the
picture elsewhere in the country because
we have had uh the turnout figures at
midday uh french time and according to
the french interior ministry 25
of eligible voters have actually cast
their ballot
it's low but it's not drastically low
it's three points uh lower than it was
in 2017 there were 28 percent uh had
cast their votes at around the same time
but you know there has been little
enthusiasm for this election it really
seems as if the campaign's never really
uh got off the ground you might say
that's at least what many people have
been saying in uh recent weeks and
people are feeling quite weary we've had
the covert pandemic for a couple of
years people are very preoccupied
looking at the war in ukraine and there
is this sense that we saw in 2017
amongst people that they're simply fed
up with the political system they're fed
up with politicians they're fed up of uh
politics and they don't feel massively
motivated nevertheless they certainly
have a certain amount of choice you've
got 12 presidential candidates
everything from anti-capitalists to the
far right and everything in between
including uh the french president
emmanuel macron who wants a second term
his main challenger marine le pen of the
far right has certainly run a very tight
campaign according to her supporters
then we might have jeanette malon
from the far left also posing something
of a challenge perhaps even making it uh
to the second round it is interesting
though i was speaking to one woman a bit
earlier who said to me that she hankered
for the old days she said uh back then
you had two main political parties in
france you had the conservatives on the
right you had the socialists on the left
and she said it actually made it so much
easier to pick
and natasha let's take us through
the some of the key issues which are
facing voters right now
well the main concern really for most
voters in france has been
the cost of living it is something that
people will talk about repeatedly
wherever you are in the country they are
seeing prices rise the the cost of food
uh the cost of petrol people are very
worried indeed about uh about their bank
accounts about their money at the end of
the month they're struggling financially
it was an issue during the yellow vest
protest a few years ago it is still an
issue today and that is also linked to
another big concern
in this election that of course is
russia's invasion of ukraine people
looking at that very carefully indeed
they see a war in europe they see europe
in crisis some of them are frightened
they're worried and they see the impact
also
on prices
other issues immigration of course that
has played very heavily in this campaign
particularly uh with uh the far-right
parties and the uh emergence last year
of a new uh face in this race if you
like eric zamor a former tv pundit who
is also taken a very tough and hard line
on immigration and then you have other
issues things like climate change they
haven't actually been uh perhaps at the
forefront of many people's minds during
this election perhaps they haven't been
a top of a gender topic for some of the
candidates but still of course one of
the main uh one of the main issues for
some
all right thanks so much and fascia
butler there
well emmanuel macron is a former banker
and economic adviser to president
francois hollande
his centrist party aims to draw support
from the mainstream left and right as
president he introduced unpopular
pension reforms and faced the country's
long-running yellow vest protests
marine le pen is running for president
for the third time she succeeded her
father as leader of the far-right
national front party rebranding it as
the national rally
staying in paris victor male is the
paris bureau chief for the financial
times and joins us good to have you with
us
so is it the cost of living that is the
deciding question for most voters
i think i think
that's true i mean your correspondence
mentioned it and it is the issue that
has really come up in the last few weeks
of the campaign and it is the thing that
people are most concerned about and it's
also the
uh the theme that marine le pen has
actually gone on about quite a lot very
successfully on her sort of trips around
the country to the villages and
towns across the country and she's
emphasized that rather than emphasizing
the policies for which she's better
known which are essentially
anti-immigration policies and uh
hostility towards nato and the eu so
this issue of prices cost of living uh
although it's actually less severe in
france than it is in other european
countries it's still very much the kind
of theme of the campaign let me jump in
then let me jump in and ask you this
question because it was really
interesting that you mentioned there in
the last few weeks i'm wondering is
there a connection with the war in
ukraine
in terms of both the rising cost of of
living in france the cost of petrol and
and so on and also the pivot in the in
the rhetoric of of candidates like
marine le pen as you mentioned they're
pivoting away from
attacking nato and eu and towards other
issues
yeah i mean i think you're right the the
certainly the war sort of very
steeply pushed up the cost of petrol and
and diesel uh and gas although actually
the french consumer is not with vehicle
fuel but with home heating and so on
they're actually quite protected
from those price rises of gas for
example because they have a lot of
nuclear electricity and they have a
system that allows the government to to
limit limit prices quite a lot but but
it's also true that the even before the
ukraine war um uh the immigration as an
issue had gone off the boil a little bit
it was very much uh boosted by eric
zamor when he came onto the scene last
year who seems to be even more extreme
certainly more vociferous about
immigration and about islam than marine
le pen has been but so even even uh you
know earlier this year before the
invasion had actually started there was
a tendency to think more about economic
issues i think and marine le pen sensed
that and and made that very much the
heart of her campaign
interesting
if macron doesn't win this one
is it fair to say france is going to
have or the french political scene is
going to have a major shift it's either
we're going
much further right or much further left
uh yes i mean uh when you say win this
one i mean what we're facing now is the
first round where it's going to be
narrowed down essentially to two
candidates and if macron is not in that
in that second round if he doesn't
qualify today he is likely to do so but
there is a small possibility that
that the second round will be between
melanchol the far left and marine le pen
of the far right if that happens
definitely we we know that we will face
a very very substantial uh sort of
geopolitical crisis if you like because
france because whichever candidate wins
in that case they will be more or less
anti-eu and anti-nato at least very
skeptical about those to those two
institutions um if if macron gets into
the second round as expected then he has
to beat le pen and he will very much be
focusing on that issue of uh you know
france's place in the world
of uh you know what what we do about the
ukraine war how how important europe is
from his point of view uh and he will be
contrasting himself very much with le
pen who is probably likely to be the
person with him in the second round all
right let's broaden it out for our
global audience and and talk about this
election in terms bigger than france
what's at stake here is it
is this election basically going to
determine whether european populism
anti-eu
anti-multilateralism is ascendant or
descended is is that what's also at
stake here
well yes but i would say that even if uh
york city right but even if marine le
pen does not win this one she is almost
certain to have the highest score that
the far right has ever had in a
presidential election in france which
means that the threat will be greater
than it's ever been
even if she doesn't actually become
president on april 24th so
whichever way you look at it
it is very much still in the ascendant i
think the whole the whole sort of
movement towards nationalism towards
populism if you like uh certainly
towards sort of hostility towards
globalism or globalists like uh like
emmanuel macron you know we saw it with
the election of donald trump uh in 2016
we saw it before that in the same year
with the brexit vote
and we've seen it in many other
countries around the world where sort of
uh you know anti-internationalist very
nationalist very populist leaders tend
to tend to win power
all right it's good to get your thoughts
thanks so much for joining us victor
thank you